si le public est venu nombreux c'est
pour fêter les 900 ans de la cathédrale
mais aussi pour un célèbre musicien
renaud capuçon c'est quand même lui qui
nous fait venir s'ils avaient pas renaud
capuçon vous seriez venu quand même ce
soir
le violoniste de renommée internationale
renaud capuçon lui découvre la
cathédrale d'autun
ils interprètent une oeuvre de camille
saint saëns sous la direction de la chef
deborah ou allemagne
camille saint saëns et un immense
compositeur français qui a beaucoup
écrit pro de violents notamment ces
randos capriccioso qui est très fameux
très virtuose et je suis très heureux du
raid pour la première fois ici à autun
dans cette sublime cathédrale entre le
lieu et les musiciens l'alchimie se fait
et l'émotion est au rendez vous
[Musique]
à l'origine de ce concert exceptionnel
la pianiste autunoise pauline perrin
les renault depuis 20 ans et deborah
depuis 15 ans et ça ce concert ce soir a
permis une première rencontre entre des
bourgs aéronautes c'est la première fois
qu'ils jouent ensemble je suis ravi ravi
pour eux
un dernier concert est prévu pour fêter
ses 900 ans avec les stentors ces
chanteurs d'opéra célébreront noël ici
le 12 décembre prochain
[Musique]